making this movie we're making a
mesquite an organic mesquite
coconut date banana kale which is what
is organic and steam powder mesquite
powder is a color I actually found it
it's in kind of a new discoveries from
northern Argentina and it's a something
that you can use in place of cacao and
it tastes like cacao okay so let's try
so on joycie welcome to holiday cooking
is this in our cookbook no this is a new
recipe so I didn't want to bother you I
wanted to give you some new things so
again get ready to go to Thanksgiving
dinner or to your holiday meal and what
if you woke up in the morning and has
had this first ok organic apple juice
organic banana a few days we're just
going to pull the seat out rich you can
throw that raw coconut in with the shows
working again where do you get this at
Whole Foods
you can get it or you can buy a dinosaur
kale
and then we put chia seeds in there does
it tables good table things
chia seeds our ancient Aztec runner food
runner food so they keep you hydrated
it's widely considered to be an
endurance booster if you read the book
Born to Run
exactly
we're gonna put some coconut oil in
great brain food
it's early in the morning before I go to
face the family for the holidays so I'm
gonna need mine all of my faculties I'm
gonna put really two of these in there
even though this is a chocolate evening
you have this proper breakfast oh yeah
easy and better yet if you have it you
know I just wheat you so at night
sometimes I want some chocolate or
something
it feeds my body and I wake up great if
you put what about face
no I'm you know you tend to like ice
more than I do and there are times of
the earth where I like ice but as a
general rule I don't like to shock my
body by drinking ice so it's easier to
digest it's cold that apple juice is
cold but we don't need to go crazy
let's check it out and also it has kale
in it so I always put something green in
the cacao or mesquite drinks in this
case let's check it out